you
all right let's get right to it
yes we will discuss china i've spent
some time with xi jinping and uh we're i
hope we're gonna get a chance to discuss
president biden and charles michelle the
president of the european council there
at the europa building in brussels in
this set of urgent and emergency
meetings among world leaders discussing
russia and its attack on ukraine which
happened one month ago rhonda colvin we
were just talking about unity and the
theme of unity okay so as far as i
believe the press conference itself is
still scheduled for half an hour from
now it's it's all kind of confusing
because i guess there was some kind of
press conference
an hour ago
um
i i i have to admit i'm a little bit
confused because it was scheduled for 40
minutes from now
uh but he did a press conference we're
we're just gonna keep it here
under the
maybe assumption that
it's all coming up
uh
let me see biden press conference
um let's see here
yeah it's every time he travels it's all
it always gets extremely confusing with
the
time change
where
nobody knows what the hell is going on
all right so we're going to keep it here
and we're going to continue monitoring
it
but i as far as i know it's at the top
of the hour so that may have been an
earlier thing and then now he's in a
short meeting and then he gives another
press conference okay so we're gonna
watch it all but i have so many things
for you guys just because some people
miss it let's just very quickly do the
mango song
mangoes my bags are mangoes
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost eleven
dollars
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes manga aren't measures like
three by seats
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
bring my mango back down
the wisconsin crowd identifying for the
mangoes
fully affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy don't
[Music]
[Music]
all right now i feel like we're actually
ready to start okay so whether or not
the press conference is at the top of
the hour if the press conference was the
thing an hour ago then we'll look we'll
just look at that at the top of the hour
but in the meantime i have so many other
things to talk to you guys about here's
one thing i'm trying to figure out
this morning i appeared on the daily
wire the michael knowles show
and i have the full clip we're going to
be publishing it in 35 minutes to our
youtube channel
do we want to look at that now is that
something we would want to look at now i
haven't reviewed the appearance i think
it went fine
is that something we would want to look
at
the only thing is i might have i might
have to ask you guys for a favor though
i need 11 000 votes give me a break no a
legal favor okay so let's look at it
because i'm so interested in it myself
but
just promise me that when we publish
this to our youtube channel in 30
minutes you'll like like it and comment
and share and stuff like that okay so
they invited me on the michael knowles
show this is sort of like one of the
subsidiary shows of ben shapiro's daily
wire
they wanted to talk about um the
definition of woman and why katanji
brown jackson didn't answer it or
whatever
so let's just jump in and uh see see
sort of how it went okay here's we'll
we'll all be reviewing it together for
the first time we are
not giving the best argument for the
other side or that we simply don't
understand what the other side is saying
so in the interest of actually hearing
out the other side i'm very pleased to
bring on david pakman who is the host of
the david pakman show it's a nationally
syndicated progressive tv show and yes i
did have a [ __ ] eating green on my face
for a lot of the interview because i
just i can't take this seriously you
guys know that and radio show i'm always
really grateful to progressives who come
on this show we invite lots of them on
very often they say no sometimes they
come on so just to make sure we're not
strong manning anything uh let's bring
on david david thank you so much for
coming on the show
it's a unique pleasure to be here
michael thank you so david
you saw the clip you've been watching
the katanji jackson hearings am i crazy
or should a
twice harvard-educated nominee federal
judge nominee for the supreme court who
is a woman be able to define what a
woman is
i can't say if you're crazy that would
be for a mental health professional
you're either dishonest or ignorant and
we can maybe figure out which so so
here's the deal i mean i'm kind of you
know what we're just meeting each other
i'm sort of kidding around but here's
the deal um
there are no uh instances where when
issues come before the supreme court
it comes down to the dictionary
definition of a word uh when it comes to
who counts as a woman or what is
discrimination or what is negligence
it's always in very narrow circumstances
where dictionary definitions do almost
nothing for you
so she was very smart
not to play into these kind of
rhetorical black holes because whatever
definition she gives michael
she then is going to be pushed into some
corner with some case or article or book
she hasn't read by the way
and there's no upside to it so if we're
just having a good faith conversation
about strategy
she did the right thing
almost 60 of americans believe she's
qualified and she is and that's really
all there is to it it's kind of boring
well i agree with her i don't agree with
you that it's boring i think it's one of
the most interesting questions in the
country that we're now at a point where
we can no longer even define man or
woman but i do agree with you on
strategy she's in a very tough spot
because her side of the aisle and she's
relatively
leftist even by the standards of the
democratic party so on her side of the
aisle so this is like you see i i just i
i use my face to suggest that what he's
saying is wrong you really have to pick
your battles here because i could
interrupt there and go she's really not
that far left to be perfectly honest but
but anyway you know you you kind of have
to pick your battles a new
definition of woman well they haven't
given the definition of woman but it's
it's not the old definition of woman
which is a person who's not a man that
is out because of the transgender
movement and so like that's another
thing where it's like no the the
definition of woman was never everyone
who's not a man because you had intersex
people for example so so like that's
also wrong but again you you can't
interrupt every single time she knows
that if she gives this new definition
which is a woman is
i don't know a woman is someone who says
that he or she is a woman that's going
to alienate i think the majority the
vast majority of americans if she gives
the old definition that a woman is
a female human being and wait is biden
speaking now
no he's not
okay what are people talking about no
he's not speaking all right let's
continue female is of or denoting the
sex that can bear children and reproduce
and you know produce eggs for instance
uh she knows that that will alienate her
base and she knows that that now is
apparently controversial in the law
after the boss stock decision after
other transgender decisions so i
understand the strategy
but what about
the law what about the definition you
say she doesn't she shouldn't be quoting
the dictionary well fine shouldn't she
at least be able to give the legal
definition of a woman shouldn't she a
woman have some sense of what that is
i'm not a meteorologist i can tell you
if it's raining
yeah there is no legal definition of a
woman and that's exactly the point the
point here is when it comes to the court
the court is in a position or will be in
a position or might be in a position to
decide for the purposes of a particular
set of facts based on a claim brought by
someone who appeals a case
about these issues and so it's it's
literally irrelevant to her job as a
supreme court justice and so again
we can have a cultural discussion
outside of the context of the supreme
court in the the senate's job in
evaluating is she qualified it's an
irrelevant question and by her
qualifications she's she's more
qualified than any of the nine justices
currently on the court there's no way to
deny that i think you can because i
think all of the nine justices on the
court can tell you what a woman is
saying so i know we're getting back have
they been asked because they've never
been asked to do that no nobody's ever
been asked to define words in this way
during hearings so you can speculate but
they've never been asked they've never
been asked
i've never but i i i as a gambling man i
would bet the farm that justice alito
could tell you what a woman is but
you're right they've never been asked
because it's never been controversial
before but i want to get to a point you
just made you said there's no legal
definition you guys see how he ver they
brazenly move the goal posts he goes
every other justice
has she's the only one every other
justice is defined woman and then i go
actually none of them have and he goes
well they've never been asked right
that's what i'm saying yeah we agree and
of a woman but there must be because
there are legal protections specifically
for women so if we don't know what a
woman is then the title three thing
title
and title is quite controversial good
faith conversation or one that's in some
way productive you know
you're saying you and i or you're saying
katanji jackson yeah i don't know if i
mean listen the republican senators
obviously didn't want to have a good
faith conversation i was i was talking
about you and i michael yes well i do
want to i mean this this is why i'm
granting you the you're making the point
on political strategy i totally grant
you that that was the right move for her
to make if she wants to avoid evidence
but but then bring up title ix i mean
there is there are legal protections for
women this is coming before the court
it's come before the court in the last
term they're going to be a lot more
cases coming before the court coming up
it seems extraordinarily relevant that
we know what this woman thinks of these
issues and of a basic question of
biology and human nature what is a woman
i mean i i don't think that's a bad
faith question for the senators or for
me to ask no it's so it's not
necessarily bad faith but we have to be
able to as i what i hope are reasonable
people michael understand that in the
context of her role as a supreme court
justice it doesn't come down to a
biological opinion like dude is that can
you at least grant that piece it's true
that for what the supreme court decides
these are narrow issues where when it
comes to obamacare's constitutionality
which amy comey coney barrett never you
know would refuse to weigh in on or that
what with all of these things these are
really narrow legal decisions and there
is no way in which a dictionary
definition definition of terms does
anything for us well it might do
something but i grant your point a
little bit except that marsha blackburn
didn't ask for the biological definition
or the dictionary definition that's what
katanji jackson added she said i'm not a
biologist but all marcia blackburn asked
was just tell me what a woman is from a
legal perspective a constitutional
perspective a philosophical i mean
whatever whatever that's literally not
what marsha blackburn said i would
encourage you to pull the clip and
identify she's the name of which she
said that she said she didn't mention
biology and she didn't mention the
dictionary she said but you just
asserted that she said she wanted the
legal and philosophical she never said
no no no no no no no no no no no i
didn't say that i said she no no i i
just said marsha blackburn asked for the
definition
any sort of definition that kanji
jackson could give of women she didn't
specified by backtracking i'm not
backtracking
look he just said it like just go back
here he said
the legal and philosophical like it was
20 seconds before and now he says i
never said that all marcia blackburn
asked was just tell me what a woman is
from a legal perspective a
constitutional perspective he that he
just said it
then he denies it 20 seconds later
philosophical i mean whatever whatever
is literally not what marsha blackburn
said i would encourage you to pull the
clip and identify she said name it which
she said that she said she didn't
mention biology and she didn't mention
the dictionary she said what you just
asserted that she said she wanted the
legal and philosophical she never said
no no no no no no no no no i didn't say
that i said she no no i
come on guys i mean this this is what i
talk about where the reason i don't do
this often is it is a waste of time i
just said marsha blackburn asked for the
definition
any sort of definition that katanji
jackson could give that's not what
that's not what he just said she said 20
seconds prior woman she didn't specified
by you're backtracking i'm not
backtracking i'm not dishonest now i'm
not back first tell my background no no
no no no no hold on a second let's let's
be clear
30 seconds ago you said marsha blackburn
didn't ask for the biological she
actually the legal no
let me let me finish the sentence
okay but you're misrepresenting what i
said
guys am i misrepresenting what he said i
mean we looked at it twice now i'm not i
would encourage the audience to rewind
why i would encourage that i would
encourage that as well but first but can
i even get it out sure is there i mean
it's okay the problem with what you just
did michael is you just said blackburn
asked for the legal definition and i
said no she didn't and you said no
that's true she actually just knows for
the definition i'm sorry well then if if
either you misheard or it seemed that i
misspoke
that's genius if i
if i misheard
or
thought he
misspoke it's like dude no you you just
bailed on what you said because you know
it wasn't actually what took place be
very clear she marcia blackburn just
said what's the definition of a woman
she didn't specify anything
uh oh what's going on now we just look
at the feed here here we go hold on
continue marcia blackburn just said
what's the definition of a woman she
didn't specify any
oh man what's going on
let's see if i refresh it but i i go
back to 753.
now you then said that biology has no
place here or that uh the dictionary
definition has no place but that's not
what marsha blackburn asked for she just
asked a simple understand that in these
supreme court hearings
the senators can ask the questions
however they want and the nominees can
answer them however they want or not
answer them my opinion is this is my
opinion and you can have a different one
and that's the great thing about america
michael uh my opinion is that if you're
like obviously i don't really say crap
like that i it's that's me just not even
taking this seriously interviewing for
the job of supreme court justice it's
reasonable to assume the questions have
a legal bearing as to your role on the
court
given that
judge jackson was right
to
understand the point of the question is
to back her into a rhetorical corner
about legal definitions and she was
right to say it's not something i can
answer these are narrow issues when they
come before the court and there's no
reason that she would ask such a
question when i do you know this guy
jesse lee peterson have you heard of him
i know jesse lee peterson when i was on
with jesse he said to me david define
what love is and what a man is and it's
a it's a really common rhetorical
technique for the bad faith right to
start with just pick a word and define
it and use it to back someone into a
rhetorical corner it's a waste of time
michael let's t let's talk about real
issues please okay oh i i think that as
a
philosophical issue but certainly as a
legal issue too the definition of a
woman
does matter has mattered recently it
will matter soon but but i i i at least
agree with you on the stream you have
not convinced me of uh judge jackson's
uh
good faith uh
confirmation hearing but you have
convinced me that she is a wise
politician
and that she's uh she's playing her hand
the best now at that point i could have
said
she's not a politician she's a judge but
again you know that she can
before i let you go david i know we're
like way over i i'm not i'm really not
playing the game of giving you some
impossible thing to define but since the
question of woman is up in the air
everyone's arguing over what it means
these days do you have
either you yourself or you speaking for
the progressives do you have a working
definition that you would use
no i don't do like i told jessie lee
peterson and there's so many that this
this interview is feeling a lot like
that one interestingly enough um i don't
do dictionary i do politics and so now i
just i don't spend time defining words
and here's here's the in all seriousness
michael yeah um
let's now talk philosophically really
we're talking you know man to man now
dictionaries are descriptive even use of
man-to-man is like you know
it i i'm not choosing that as part of my
like regular vocabulary you guys know
that right i mean okay not proscriptive
so they're prescriptive sometimes too
but yeah
but they can be descriptive they can be
they are descriptive and prescriptive as
well right the word
by definition humans decide what to put
in the dictionary right so they're just
the these are
scripted but they put it there because
the words at the time believe yeah i
mean we could we could go down a tangent
on prescriptivism versus descriptivism
and that might be good for a future
appearance to tangent but i no it's it
would be a very good discussion and uh
and i i think would be great to have you
back i appreciate that i truly truly
appreciate your coming on and giving uh
the
progressive perspective on this and i
hope to have you back on the show where
can people find you in the meantime
davidpakman.com and it's been my
unbridled pleasure to provide you these
insights
thank you david very much i appreciate
all right so there it is uh that was my
appearance on uh the daily wire
uh
and anyway so we'll be publishing that
at the top of the hour let's let's see
what we can do with it when i was last
time i was on fox it did i think it got
a million views i don't think this will
but it was still fun you know sort of
it's just
his show is early they record early in
the morning they send 10 emails you've
got to do a test connection with them
and
it's just like i have very busy days
which is why i don't normally
do this stuff
but um
anyway so that's what it was i want to
say thank you to bowflex man sheldon
aleene as well as wookie jack and jen
here for the four twitch prime
subscriptions before we go to the biden
press conference i do want to just
you know what as you guys all know
when things get tough
i look for the moral um clarity
and insights of tulsi
um
and so i want to see now tulsi says
she's being censored because her videos
on instagram aren't getting the right
number of views before coming on your
show today i found out that instagram
which is owned by facebook
is also suppressing my voice uh normally
on average videos she fits in right she
fits in beautifully with the american
right which is i'm i'm a i'm a victim
everybody's targeting me
they're all doing horrible things to me
i am the epitome of the victim
um
man that i post on instagram gets
somewhere between 250 300 000 views
tens of thousands of likes the video
that i posted uh last night or early
this morning got about ten percent of
that fifteen thousand around fifteen
thousand views now this could be for a
whole bunch of different reasons it
could be that there were russian troll
elements that were supporting uh her
content and now they aren't that's
possible it could be that when you post
stuff really late at night or early in
the morning it just doesn't do as well
we know that at the david pakman show if
i post a video at 1 am eastern i don't
expect it to do well
and then the third part is who cares
and a couple of thousand likes and it is
very clear that they are doing all they
can to suppress uh my voice suppress uh
the message that i'm carrying out and at
instagram they meet and they go you know
what we really gotta do today you know
what we've gotta do and we will ban men
no we we're going to suppress tulsi
her message is too powerful we must
suppress it this points to yet another
example of this larger machine that is
very clearly
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines work that is
controlling our marketplace of ideas and
this machine is made up of the power
lead it's made up of these big social
media tech giants it's made up of the
politicians the powerful politicians
from both parties uh in washington the
military-industrial complex people who
feel directly challenged when anyone
dares to question their narrative the
message that they want
okay so anyway if you were wondering
about what's happening with tulsi's
instagram
now we know
uh another bit of news
north korea
is now uh testing a missile
okay
um associated press reporting north
korea test fired possibly its biggest
intercontinental ballistic missile
towards the sea thursday
raising the ante in a pressure campaign
aimed at forcing the us to accept it as
a nuclear power
and remove crippling sanctions
uh south korea's military responded with
live fire drills of its own missiles
launched from land a fighter jet and a
ship
so that's going on i don't know that i
have too too much else to
say about it thank you to spinach
monster and foster
for the twitch prime subscriptions
let's now
if i may
get into the biden press conference
good evening everyone
with all the press is here you must be
getting very tired
am i the 16th or 17th
anyway all kidding decide thank you uh
for taking the time
i uh
today marks one month since russia
began its carnage in ukraine the brutal
invasion of ukraine
and uh we held a nato summit the very
next day
at that time my overwhelming objective
wanting that summit
was to have absolute unity on three key
important issues among our nato and
european allies first was
to support ukraine
with military and humanitarian
assistance
second was
to impose the most significant the most
significant sanctions economic sanction
regime ever in order to [ __ ] putin's
economy and punish him for his actions
third was to fortify the eastern flank
of our nato allies who were obviously
very very concerned and somewhat at
worry to what would happen
we accomplished all three of these that
today were determined to sustain those
efforts
and to build on them
the united states is committed to
provide over 2 billion dollars in
military equipment to ukraine since i
became president
and i air systems and i armor systems
and yeah there's a weird audio thing
where it sounds like one of those uh
australian musical instruments i i it's
just it's in the audio ammunition
and our weapons are flowing in ukraine
as i speak
and today i'm announcing the united
states are prepared to commit
more than one billion dollars in
humanitarian assistance to help get
relief to millions of ukrainians
affected by the war in ukraine
many ukrainian refugees will uh will
wish to stay in europe closer to their
homes
but we also will welcome 100 000
ukrainians united states with a focus on
reuniting families
and we will invest 320 million dollars
to bolster democratic resilience and
defend human rights in ukraine and
neighboring countries we're also
coordinating
with the g7 and the european union on
food security as well as energy security
i'll have more to say about that
tomorrow
we're also announcing new sanctions of
more than 400 individuals and entities
aligned with in alignment with the
european union
more than 300 members of the douma
oligarchs and russian defense companies
that fuel the russian war machine
in addition to the 100 000 u.s forces
now stationed in europe to defend nato
territory
nato established as you already know
four new battle groups from romania
hungary
bulgaria and slovakia to reinforce the
eastern front
putin was banking on nato being split
my early conversation with him in
december and early january was clear to
me he didn't think we could sustain this
cohesion
nato has never never been more united
than it is today
putin is getting exactly the opposite
what he intended to have as a
consequence of going into ukraine
we've built that same unity with our
european the european union and with the
leading democracies of the g7 in the g7
so i want to thank you
and i'll be now happy to take your
questions since there's so many people
out there i'm gonna be giving a list now
how about chris yeah the audio sounds
like a didgeridoo
it is very weird all right let's
continue the press
first question
so you've warned about the real threat
of chemical weapons being used have you
gathered specific intelligence that
suggests that president putin is
deploying these weapons moving in the
position or considering their use and
would the u.s or nato respond with
military action if he did use chemical
weapons you know the first question i
can't answer that i'm not going to give
you intelligence data number one number
two
we would respond we would respond if he
uses it the nature of the response would
depend on the nature of the use
uh
josh bloomberg
[Music]
perhaps i'll just project mr president
uh thank you very much you fired your
voice out of my elect a lot earlier i'll
give it a try he's got a long arm thank
you uh can you uh talk guys that the the
the the audio and the visuals at this
press conference are beyond parody i
mean it's about what is that about a 25
foot long boom mic two things sir one
since your conversation with president
xi of china have you seen any
indications of action or
lack of action from china that has led
you to believe whether they will
intervene and help russia either with
the sale of arms
did the thing almost just hit him in the
face
this is look at that there's there's
[Laughter]
oh god the these this whole political
world is just it's crazy
let's i want i gotta see that again
[Music]
can you uh talk to us about two things
sir one sincere conversation with
president xi of china have you seen any
indications of action or
lack of action from china that has led
you to believe whether they will
intervene and help russia either with
the sale of arms
or
oh my god what is happening the shaking
and then it drops and almost hits him in
the face or the provision of supplies to
support this war in ukraine and secondly
uh can you say whether this uh the
conversation today turned to the subject
oh there's another reporter holding it
oh god it's it's you couldn't script
this do you guys see how there's another
reporter holding it
that is unbelievable this is the best
food shortages and what the us will do
to address wheat shortages in particular
as a result of this war thank you on the
first question relating to president xi
jinping of china
i had a a very straightforward
conversation with
she uh now i guess it's uh six days ago
seven days ago in that range
and uh
i uh
made it clear to him i made no threats
but i made it clear to him
that make sure he understood the
consequences of him helping russia as
had been reported and as as what was
expected
and uh
i made no threats but i pointed out the
number of
american and foreign corporations that
left russia as a consequence of their
barbaric behavior
and i indicated that
i knew how much he because we had long
discussions in the past
about his interest in making sure he had
economic relations and economic growth
with europe and the united states
and indicated that he'd be putting
himself in significant jeopardy and
those
in those aims if in fact he were to move
forward
i am not going to comment on any detail
about what we know or don't know
as a consequence of that conversation
but uh
tomorrow is
tomorrow or next monday that ursula is
having that conference with china
the first
on on april 1st we've had discussions
because i think that
china understands that
uh its economic future is much more
closely tied to the west
than it is to russia
and so i i i'm hopeful
that he
he does not get engaged
we also did discuss today
that there's a need for us to set up
nato to set up and and the eu
to set up a system whereby we have an
organization looking at
who has violated any of the sanctions
and where and when and how they violated
that's interesting and that's something
we're going to put in train it's not
done yet
so uh with regard to uh
she i
i have not nothing more to report with
regard to food shortage yes we did we
talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
and because both
russia and ukraine
have been the bread basket of europe in
terms of wheat for example just give one
example
but we had a long discussion uh in the
g7
with
the
with both
the united states which has a
significant the third largest producer
of wheat in the world
as well as canada which is also a major
major producer
and we both talked about how we could
increase and disseminate more rapidly
food shortages in addition to that
we talked about
urging all the european countries and
everyone else to
end trade
restrictions on sending uh
limitations on sending food abroad
and so we are in the process of working
out with our european friends
what it would be what it would take to
help alleviate the concerns relative to
food shortages we also talked about a
significant major u.s investment among
others in terms of providing for
the need for
humanitarian assistance including food
as we move forward
to reina of the wall street journal
watch out you're not hitting the head
there now
mr president in your view does president
zielinski need to cede any ukrainian
territory in order to gain a ceasefire
with russia or is that completely off
the table good question and then also do
you think uh that russia needs to be
removed from the g20 beautiful
on the latter point my answer is yes
that depends on the g20 wow um i
that was raised today and
i raised the possibility if that can't
be done if indonesia and others do not
agree
that we should in my view
ask to have
both
ukraine
be able to attend the meetings
as well
as well
basically ukraine being able to attend
the g20 meeting that's interesting
with regard to what was the first
question
that is a total judgment based on
ukraine
nothing about ukraine without ukraine
i don't believe that they're going to
have to do that but that's a judgment
there's negotiations that are
discussions i should say yes so the
point here is it's conceivable that
ukraine may cede some territory to
russia and whatever eventual ceasefire
agreement is made they've taken place
that i have not been part of including
ukrainians
and it's uh it's it's third judgment to
make
um
cecilia abc
there you are
sir you've made it very clear in this
conflict that you do not want to see
world war iii but is it possible that in
expressing that so early that you were
too quick to rule out direct military
intervention in this war could putin
have been emboldened knowing that you
are not going to get involved directly
in this conflict interesting question no
one no
and to clarify on chemical weapons could
if chemical weapons were used in ukraine
would that trigger a military spot
response from nato
it would be it would trigger a response
in kind whether or not you're asking
whether nato would cross
we'd make that decision at the time my
final question because you're heading to
poland tomorrow do you think that
getting a first-hand look at the effects
of this war
on these millions of ukrainians who have
fled their country could change the way
that you might respond
i don't think so because i've been to
many many war zones i've been as
refugee camps i've been in war zones for
the last 15 years and it's it's it's
devastating and but the thing you look
at the most is you see these young
children you see children without
parents that are in those camps or in
refugees
you see women and husbands and men and
women who are completely lost and have
no nose you see the look that blank look
on their face
that absolute feeling of my god
where am i what's going to happen to me
and so
it what it will do and will reinforce my
commitment to have the united states
make sure we are a major piece of
dealing with the relocation of all those
folks as well as humanitarian assistance
needed both inside ukraine and outside
ukraine for example this is not
something that poland or romania or
germany should carry on their own
this is an international responsibility
the united states is the leader one of
the leaders of the international
community has an obligation to be
engaged to be engaged and do all we can
to ease the suffering and pain
of innocent women and children and men
for that matter throughout the
throughout ukraine
and those who have made it across the
border i plan on attempting to see those
folks as well as i hope i'm going to be
able to see
i guess i'm not supposed to say where
i'm going am i
but anyway i hope i get to see
a lot of people
um
marcus der spiegel
thanks mr president
um
there is a presidential election coming
up in 2024 and as you know there are
white yes
that's true
and there are widespread concerns in
europe that
a figure like your predecessor maybe
even your predecessor himself
might get elected president again
um so um are there any steps anything
you are trying to do and nato is trying
to do here these days
to prevent
what you're trying to do becoming undone
two years from now thank you no that's
not how i think of this i've been
dealing with foreign policy
for longer than anybody is involved in
this process right now
i have no concerns about
the impact i made a commitment when i
ran this time
i wasn't going to run again and i mean
that sincerely i had no intention of
running for president again
and uh until i saw
those folks coming out of the fields in
virginia carrying torches and carrying
nazi banners and literally
singing the same
vile
rhyme that they used in germany in the
early 20s
30s i should say
and
then when the gentleman you mentioned
was asked what he thought and a young
woman the gentleman you mentioned isn't
that just the the best just killed a
protester
and he asked what was asked what he
thought
he said they're very good people on both
sides
and that's when i decided i wasn't going
to be quiet any longer
and
when i ran this time and i think the
american press whether they look at me
favorably or favor will acknowledge this
i made a determination
nothing is worth
no election is worth my not doing
exactly what i think is the right thing
not a joke
i'm too long in the tooth to fool with
this any longer not a joke and so
we're a long way off in elections a long
way off
my focus of any election is on making
sure that we retain the house of the
united states senate so that i have the
room to continue to do the things that
i've been able to do right in terms of
grow the economy and deal
in a rational way with american foreign
policy and
lead the world
lead be the leader of the free world so
uh um but it's not a it's not a logical
question for someone to ask
i say to people at home
imagine if we sat and watched the
uh the doors of the bundestag broken
down and
police officers killed and hundreds of
people storming in or imagine if we saw
that happening in the british parliament
or whatever how would we feel
and
one of the things that i take some
solace from
is i don't think you'll find any
european leader
who uh
thinks that uh
i am not up to the job
um
i mean that's absolutely it's not like
whoa it's that's that the point is that
one the first g7 meeting i attended like
the one i did today
was in great britain and i sat down and
i said america's back
and one of the one of my counterparts
colleagues as head of state said for how
long
for how long
and so i don't blame i don't i don't
criticize anybody for asking that
question
but uh
the next election i'd be very fortunate
if i had
that same man running against us
one final question right hey the way
hold on a second please
i was supposed to be an hour ago at the
european union meeting and to speak now
i'm thanking you
so someone i haven't called on before
you
who are you i'm christina
okay
sir deterrence didn't work
what makes you think vladimir putin will
alter course based on the action you've
taken today let's get something straight
you remember if you covered me from the
very beginning i did not say that in
fact the sanctions would deter him
sanctions never deter
you keep talking about that
sanctions never deter
the maintenance of sanctions
the maintenance of sanctions the
increasing the pain and the
demonstration why i asked for this nato
meeting today is to be sure that after a
month we will sustain what we're doing
not just next month the following month
but for the remainder of this entire
year that's what will stump him come on
man
that's not what i said you you're
playing a game with me i know the answer
is no
i think what happens is we have to
demonstrate the purpose the single most
important thing
is for us to stay unified
and the world continue to focus on what
a brute this guy is and all the innocent
people's lives are being lost and ruined
and what's going on
that's the important thing but look if
you're putin
and you think that the
europe is going to crack
in a month or six weeks or two months
why not
they can take anything for another month
but we have to demonstrate it the reason
i asked for the meeting we have to stay
fully totally thoroughly united
mr president sir
if we could have everyone stay seated
there it is
all right so uh president joe biden
delivering
a press conference there
and uh quite a situation quite a
situation that we find ourselves facing
at this point in time
i want to say thank you to locavera
daniel get
wolf pact frosty has gifted four
subscriptions that's seven
and mazic is eight
putting us at 14.
that does it for me today short stream
lot of work to do glad everybody got
here
right now you can see my interview on
the daily wire with michael
knowles on my youtube channel
please share it please share it folks
alright we'll see everybody very soon